[Music]
science world and we're gonna learn the
split time version of our same time
turns we have our same time u-turn past
the toes over the top and front up
behind the hip stand behind the
shoulders and you can do all of the
split time and that's gonna end up being
part of what blends into all your reels
and windmills so this is getting us into
our chasing moves so face this with me
and get oriented for me I've got a condo
in front of me I've got free to the
right
Stadium to the left camera behind and
I'm gonna be consistent in my directions
here so I shift it this way let's do
this with me plant your feet and here
you can shift your feet as you shift
your body but don't don't step around at
first because that will just trip you up
so you're gonna shift this way and I
first review how we do the same time
turns get them spinning passed down past
your toes over the top in front of you
up behind your hips down behind your
shoulders so let's do the two turns in
front slowly past your toes and over the
top notice it passes your toes the left
is leading past your toes and if you
come back your right is leading your
left is leading then your right is
leading so what you're going to do is
this first face this way you get
backwards split time happening
but this is how you're gonna finish
you're gonna finish in backwards split
time so if you started at your toes it
could turn to your left into backwards
split them give it a couple times your
left is already leaving so it's easy to
go flip in the backward split time then
you can start all those here same thing
left leads in the backward split time
then you're gonna start gently spinning
the place same time and when you turn
your left the left speed up a bit and
the left leads in the split time then
you're going to start in split time your
left is going to lead the right it's
going to chase the left toes toes in the
split time when you come back the same
time go over the top and as you get to
the other side let the right speed up
the back to split time so at first you
can keep doing the same time and finish
the split time start at the same time
finish and split them and then just
start in split time right when you turn
to your left your left leads past the
toes when you turn to the right the
right leads over the sky left pass the
toes right over the sky left past the
toes right over the sky boom boom boom
boom
then of course your homework does it
turn the other way and the opposite is
true as I go pass my toast the rice is
leading and they come back the left is
leading the home so I'm going to learn
to let the right lead in the split time
and when I come back the left leads in
the split time and then from split time
the right leads coming back the left
leads so he knew it this way and then
pretty soon you'll be turning you can go
on this side and back and this side and
back or this side and keep turning and
this is becoming smile post BAM
and coming soon how to do the trends
behind
[Music]